[Applaudissements]
d'abord je tiens à saluer les acteurs à
l'origine de cette très belle initiative
littéraire qui se tient depuis 1992
il me semble et ce grâce à qui en fait
le prix renaudot des lycéens existe donc
les amis de théophraste renaudot
également merci au lycée guy chauvet de
nous accueillir aujourd'hui d'ouvrir
chaque année ses portes à 7 ce bel
événement qui réunit professeurs lycéens
est tout simplement amoureux de la
littérature aussi merci à tous les
partenaires que marie claire a cité
également qui permettent de faire
perdurer également ce prix mais avant
tout les lycéennes et lycéens qui sont
vraiment l'esprit et le coeur de ce pli
et qui en font en fait tout toute sa
valeur je pense que l'histoire faire du
moins le temps a permis de constater que
le prix renaudot des lycéens réussi à
s'inscrire durablement dans le paysage
littéraire français passent chaque année
en fait non seulement les médias mais
aussi le public s'intéresse à votre
choix et coûteuse ouvrage que vous avez
choisie et le mettre en avant
donc ça prouve que vont en tant que
jeune en fait vous avez une voix et une
voix qui compte donc non seulement merci
mais aussi bravo et surtout préserver
cette voie parce qu'elle est importante
en fait plus personnellement ce qui me
touche c'est que cette cette histoire
d'un autre temps vous et vous ai parlé
que ces femmes d'une autre époque vous
et vous et toucher aussi pour moi ça
signifie qu'en fait ce qui nous lie à
une histoire n'est pas une question de
genre de temps ou de lieu mais c'est
bien les questions de l'humain tout
simplement
donc voilà enfin je peux que vous dire
merci du fond du coeur venant de vous
c'est un très grand honneur et un très
grand bonheur merci pour vous donne une
voix
si vous en tant que lycéen et que ça ait
un impact aussi sur l'humanitaire c'est
pas un petit prix comme ça on en parle
en fait j'ai pris l'eau des lycéens donc
c'est important ça bravo aussi à vous en
faites qui entretenait aussi ce prix là
et qui en fait sa valeur c'est quand
même lui six livres 6 livres en un mois
et demi à peine deux mois
rappelez vous investissez en dehors des
temps de cours aussi donc ça manque
vraiment ses bras mois de la littératie
7 paris le 1er mars 1890 m'attendre
soeur
tout est blanc au dehors on ne pouvons
sortir et toucher la neige
l'espace est glacial tu imagines combien
les potages brûlant sont appréciés quand
l'heure du dîner a sonné certains un
moment j'attends des remous serment
très émouvant
avant pendant deux bonnes heures aussi
j'ai hâte en fait
très en pleine discussion avec
oui parce qu'il paraît qu'ils sont un
petit peu mordant parfois mais j'aime
bien mais très bien tant mieux
e
c'était ce matin j'ai entendu deux
extraits de votre lit
comme lui parle justement de lycéennes
qu'est ce que ça fait grand effet
aussi de
[Musique]
avec leur propre sensibilité
j'aime que j'aime en fait que les
lecteurs se soit approprié texte
maintenant il appartient au lecteur il
m'appartient plus d'accord
la partie entre hôtels bientôt au cinéma
appartenir au grand écran avec une
attelle
ils auront six
pour en dire un peu plus dans l'émotion
des acteurs
alors je n'ai pour l'instant
le choix car c'est une
mélanie laurent et compte bien mettre la
réalisation
je lui fais confiance pour eux
d'accord merci et donc ce soir on veut
vous retrouvez aussi à loudun c'est un
père portes à 20h30
et là par contre c'est avec les adultes
et il y aura une chroniqueuse qui le
fera parler
on vient
très bien avec bonne discussion donc à
messieurs avec les collégiens et lycéens
parmi ce lycéen
merci au revoir
le